c'est l'une des fêtes les plus
importantes pour les sénégalais la
tabaski la fête du sacrifice c'est
l'occasion de retrouver les proches un
peu partout dans le pays et pour ses
retrouvailles les déplacements se font
en général à bord de bus ou de voitures
bondées et c'est bien ce qui inquiète
les autorités sénégalaises le président
macky sall qui jusqu'à présent
privilégié les mesures incitatives
hausse désormais le ton et menace même
de mettre en place des mesures
sanitaires plus strictes telles que la
limitation des déplacements à
l'intérieur du pays ou encore la
limitation des rassemblements des
mesures qui seraient très mal accueillie
par la population
al'approche de la tabaski comme on a pu
le voir au marché de tilène où les
préparatifs vont bon train avant notre
naissance de musulmans à respecter les
mesures comme le com
nous irons prier à touba et après la
prière je resterai là bas deux ou trois
semaines avant de revenir ici pour
travailler même si on ferme les routes
je vais rester là bas jusqu'à
l'ouverture des routes
mais c'est sûr j'irai prix et si dieu le
veut c'est trop important
chaque année nous ne cédons la tabaski
nulle part ailleurs qu'à touba
c'est là bas qu'on al'habitude de le
fêter avec nos parents
la victime comme toutes les maladies et
selon la publicité le comique c'est en
ce sens que les gens autour qui a une
malle informations concernant le coup vu
mais il ya la police qui l'a accueilli
des milliers de personnes jakub komar
sont là des récents sondages et la peau
du comique tout le monde le sait mais le
couvert ma mère en personne il à faire
ce qu'ils font ils sont tentés de faire
semblant alors que les contaminations
sont à la hausse au sénégal le président
macky sall a déclaré qu'il était
convaincu que la vaccination massive
était la seule stratégie à adopter pour
se débarrasser définitivement de la
pandémie indices taux qui a du mal à
passer auprès des sénégalais qui reste
globalement très sceptique vis-à-vis des
vaccins anti corrida